my name is Margaret Mabry and I am the
member for Walden Field Ward and the
cabinet member for communities I was
elected in May 2015
my days are very flexible and can change
at late noticed sometimes I start at
7:00 in the morning I leave home and I
don't arrive back until late at night
the meetings can be very variable
sometimes I can have meetings all days
sometimes I can have one in the morning
one in the afternoon and one in the
evening it's very very variable and
that's one of the things that I enjoy
about being a councillor it's not 95
it's very variable the meetings can be
in the council chamber for full council
meeting they can be in a small committee
they can be with our partners they can
be within the ward they can be at parish
councils they can be with Suffolk County
Council
they are really variable so why did you
become a counselor because I was asked
to and after I had stopped laughing
because I found it he really funny I
asked the reason why and it was because
I had an opinion I attended parish
council meetings and I would ask
questions and I would have some input
into those meetings only during public
session obviously and basically I was
just asked if I would if I would stand I
had to think about it because I was
concerned about time whether I would
like to be pinned down from 9:00 to 5:00
but I was assured it wasn't like that
and I can guarantee it isn't I got
involved by attending parish council
meetings and I think if you have a real
interest in a subject the that you write
to your local board member
and also make your views clear at the
parish council meeting that is the that
is the first way in otherwise if we go
down a political route then obviously if
you're interested in a political party
what they stand for their values are the
same as yours then I would suggest that
you joined your political party and got
involved there with their meetings and
their fundraising events whatever they
are doing if you are really interested
in democracy then you should stand to be
a counselor it is no point complaining
to account solar water to your parish to
your district to your County if you have
an opinion and you have never lost it
and if you are really serious about
helping others being involved then
standing for council is for you
I have lived within the Baber district
for almost 40 years raised my children
here my children went to school here
they have been they have been successful
and happy here and I have been happy
here the whole district of Baber has a
vast expanse of country
of the coast of people if you want to
disappear for it for a moment and find
your own little corner with nobody it's
still possible it just has such a
variety and if we continue to enjoy the
area then it will continue to thrive the
very special occasion is that it's 90
years since the act of equal
representation which gave men and women
equal opportunity to vote this year is
looks over hundreds anniversary when
that some of the first women received
the vote there were conditions attached
to this voting system and it was that
women
property and be over the age of 30 and
hence it wasn't until 10 years later
that there was the equal representation
fact I also believe that this year is
very important
we are also witnessing the anniversary
of the arm of Armistice in 1918 women
had a very important role during the
First World War they took on the jobs
that men historically had done which
allowed the men to fight on the front
and women stayed at home and continued
to support the country I believe this is
a very important reason to acknowledge
democracy this week we need we need more
women in politics that I believe
currently at Weber we have 12 out of 43
and it would be nice to see a few
younger women stepping up and into the
shoes of those that who have gone before
we install so remember during 1918 that
the suffragettes and suffragists were
also working towards the votes for women
next year we have district council
elections and it would be really good to
see more women coming forward to stand
for these positions there there are
always people who can advise and who can
who can help and if you don't step
forward then there won't be women in
politics in the future I am a cabinet
member I was appointed a year ago and
this does involve much more work that is
much more like a full-time time job and
I think that perhaps the public find
this difficult to understand because
councillors are volunteers we are
classed as volunteers we do do the job
the majority of us because we believe
that that we can help people and that we
can make a difference however once you
step up and you become a cabinet member
it is slightly more structured and you
find you have more emails you have more
paperwork to read you have more
decisions to make and decision-making is
something that you must be comfortable
with there is no point in making a
decision and then worrying for days
afterwards
part of a district counselors job is
local casework and this is where you
help residents who have a particular
issue this can be widely different from
sorting out a tree perhaps that is
impacting on their life it can be trying
to work out who owns a piece of land it
can be helping someone who has a housing
issue that is a very important part of
being a district counselor you must like
people you must want to help people and
you must really enjoy solving those
problems having been elected a counselor
I found it a huge privilege the day that
I knew from their vote that I had been
elected I just could not stop smiling
because it was a really happy time for
me but then you think afterwards what
you've let yourself in for and you
realize it is a huge public privilege it
is a huge honor and at times it is very
humbling but very very enjoyable and if
anyone has an inkling to stand as a
counselor
would encourage them to do so